[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEREMY WALKER: [INAUDIBLE]
YouTube APIs.
You're probably wondering
why I have a green
screen behind me.
Well today, we're taking you
behind the scenes with
Capella's live streaming
solution to show you some of
their features.
One of them actually is
switching out backgrounds in
near real time.
So I'll switch over
to introductions.
Ikuyo, you're the CEO
of Capella Systems.
And then we have Martin, who's
one of the lead engineers.
So let's jump right into it.
Tell us a little bit of a
background on your company.
IKUYO YAMADA: So Martin
and I, we started this
company back in 2009.
Prior to starting Capella, we
were both members of a company
called Rhozet, which focused
on offering offline
transcoding software.
At Capella, we focus on live
streaming solutions for
professionals and also
enterprise level customers.
We also offer offline
transcoding solutions, mainly
focused on H.264 compression
technologies.
JEREMY WALKER: OK, cool.
So I guess the question is from
your last company to this
one, what got you into the
idea of doing this live
streaming, or why did you
decide to go into it?
IKUYO YAMADA: At the previous
company at Rhozet, we focused
a lot mainly catering to post
production houses and mainly
broadcasters.
So we sold a lot of offline
transcoding solutions.
As we were doing it, I saw
a big shift going from
traditional broadcasting
workflow to more using open
platforms like live streaming.
So we wanted to develop a
software that is specifically
designed for this new
type of broadcasting
that's emerging today.
JEREMY WALKER: So your goal is
really to make live streaming
easy to use and very simple.
IKUYO YAMADA: And our software
allows users to do that.
Our goal is to basically offer
a very reliable software that
allows users to do a
whole production on
his own or her own.
JEREMY WALKER: OK,
that makes sense.
I guess what are some of the
common issues you see with
live streaming just
in general?
IKUYO YAMADA: I think live
streaming, the whole
production, it could get
very complicated.
I see a lot of users trying
to use multiple equipment.
And sometimes the combination
of, for example, using a
particular capture board with a
live streaming solution, you
will face a lot of unexpected
issues that are very difficult
to troubleshoot.
And also, to do a very good live
streaming show, you do
need a lot of operators
who are familiar with
these kind of things.
And it's very hard to arrange
somebody to always be on site
to do that.
And my goal when we started this
company is to create a
software, even for
non-broadcasters are able to
use this, for example, like
schools, hospitals, community
groups, and corporates.
Anyone with just a little bit
of IT background is able to
use this software and do a very
high quality streaming
show on her own or his own.
JEREMY WALKER: OK.
So why did you choose the
YouTube APIs using the live
streaming API particularly?
IKUYO YAMADA: Because we do
believe that with the
availability of fast internet
and also open platforms like
YouTube, I see a lot of
professionals and also even
broadcasters are getting into
live streaming and using
YouTube live platform as a way
to deliver more streams and
contents to more viewers
around the world.
So I wanted to make it easier
for those customers to be able
to use our software that
interfaces with the YouTube
platform seamlessly.
JEREMY WALKER: OK, great.
So you guys were actually at
Google I/O. You were in the
YouTube Sandbox, and you were
showing off some of the cool
stuff you're going to
be showing now.
So let's just jump right into
the demo so we can have a look
at some of the features and then
do the some of the green
screen shenanigans I've been
talking about in our posts.
IKUYO YAMADA: Great.
Let's take a look.
So here, this is our
Cambria Live UI.
On the very left hand
side, you will
see a list of sources.
So we can take in multiple
camera inputs.
For example, we have Camera
One basically pointing at
Jeremy, and we have another
camera that's pointing to us
from a different angle.
So while you're doing streaming,
I can switch in
between different
camera inputs.
Another neat thing about our
application, it comes with a
function called VC, so I can
add Virtual Camera inputs.
JEREMY WALKER: This is
really interesting.
So it's like you just have one
camera that's taking a large
HD shot of everything, and then
you can kind of cut out a
whole bunch of virtual
cameras that you can
switch between, right?
IKUYO YAMADA: Yes.
The whole idea is just to
use a single camera.
We could kind of create this
virtual multi-camera
environment.
So it reduces the cost of
operation, and you only have
to buy one camera.
So right here, I am manipulating
captured areas.
So I have this segment
that's focused on me.
So then during the streaming,
I can go from
overview shot to VC.
So it looks as though we're
actually switching the camera
inputs, but we're only really
using a single camera input.
JEREMY WALKER: OK.
Well that's pretty neat.
IKUYO YAMADA: And also on here,
you will see the list of
targets that we can stream to.
We can stream to Adobe Flash
Media Server, Wowza, of
course, we can go to YouTube.
So if you have a YouTube Live
account, it'll bring up a list
of live events that you
have been registered
from YouTube's website.
JEREMY WALKER: And so for people
that are larger that
are doing these live shows, is
there a way that they can
claim or monetize
against these?
IKUYO YAMADA: Yeah.
So we are in the process of
integrating Partner API.
I think now it's called
Content ID API.
So actually, from an offline
transcoding software, user is
going to be able to set claim
options and also create
reference files to be uploaded
to Content ID system of Google
that creates a bunch of
fingerprint files.
JEREMY WALKER: OK, great.
And then on the ad side, you
guys are looking into adding
that as we speak--
adding some of the
functionalities for ad slates
and ad insertions and
things like that?
IKUYO YAMADA: Yes, we are in
the process of implementing
this feature.
We believe that this kind
of function will be very
appealing to our professional
and also
enterprise level customers.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
IKUYO YAMADA: So if you have a
YouTube account, then you can
specify which channel that you
want to stream to from here.
And while you're doing live
streaming to YouTube channel,
for example, you could record
an entire event to a file.
So you can use it for archiving
or for VOD.
JEREMY WALKER: And don't you
guys have a future where you
can, as you're doing it, just
take out the highlights?
IKUYO YAMADA: Yes.
So this is one of the cool
features that we have.
We have this function called
Cambria Live Edit, which
basically allows you to do proxy
editing while you're
doing streaming.
So you can set multiple
in and out points to
create highlight clips.
And that segment can be
transcoded into multiple
different file formats and, for
example, can be uploaded
to YouTube VOD channel.
JEREMY WALKER: OK, great.
So as you're having the live
event, you can be setting up a
much smaller video with
the highlights.
IKUYO YAMADA: So now, going to
the green screen demo, we are
going to do this by using our
picture in picture function.
So this allows you to combine
multiple video layers into a
single stream.
So for example, I have--
JEREMY WALKER: I know you guys
are going to bring this up,
and this was pretty popular
at our Sandbox.
And I also have your app, which
I don't know if you can
see it here, but this is an
app running on a Nexus 10.
And you can see here, this is
what they were showing, and
you can actually click.
So let's say I'm in space now,
but I want to be underwater, I
just click and see, it takes
me now to an underwater.
So this is using your
APIs, correct?
MARTIN BELLEAU: Yeah, this
is using the API.
So from this app, we can
retrieve the first image of
the different video files
that are loaded into the
application.
And then when you click here
on the tablet, it sends the
message to our REST API, which
triggers a switch of the
background.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah.
This is really cool, and of
course, our favorite YouTube
Dev sticker.
IKUYO YAMADA: And then this is
all happening in real time.
We're doing all this processing
only by using our
software, so it's a very
powerful tool.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah, and
it's pretty fun to do.
So now we're underwater.
So let's jump into the
technical details.
Now, you use a couple of
different languages, from my
understanding, on the front
end, you're using--
what language are you using?
MARTIN BELLEAU: On the front
end, we're C Sharp.
We're using WPF from Microsoft
to do the UI, so that's pretty
simple to use.
It's really productive to use.
There's a lot of libraries.
It makes it really simple to
create UIs that look nice and
are functional.
Now on the back end side, where
we do all the video
encoding, all the video
processing, the audio
processing, that's using C++.
For that kind of thing,
you need a
high performance language.
You also need something where
you have a lot of control over
memory allocation, garbage
collection, and so on.
And also, all this technology
is also cross platform
because it's C++.
JEREMY WALKER: And then you
guys are going even deeper
than that in some situations,
right?
MARTIN BELLEAU: Yes.
So in some cases, we're going
to use assembly language.
For example, for that green
screen we're showing right
now, we're using an assembly
call to composite yourself
over the background that we're
switching, and also to do
things like up-scaling video,
downscaling video.
For very precise operations,
yeah, it's
done in Assembly language.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
So I guess you guys are using
OAuth2, obviously,
with the new APIs.
So how are you doing that?
MARTIN BELLEAU: So from the UI,
we just launch a browser
window where you enter your
Google credentials, and then
after that, we grab the Refresh
token and that gets
stored on the client machine.
And then whenever we need to
authenticate again, we create
a token from that
Refresh token.
JEREMY WALKER: So it's all
on the local machine?
MARTIN BELLEAU: Yeah.
JEREMY WALKER: OK, great.
Were there any surprises, not
only with the API, but with
customers using your product
that you noticed?
MARTIN BELLEAU: Well, one
surprise was when we moved to
the new API, which was V3, it
was a pretty big change from
the previous one.
We just started working
with you guys.
Typically, APIs tend to stay
more similar through time.
But this one for V3, there
was a really big change.
Things became simpler.
And also, the other big change
was that previously, if we
wanted to stream in multiple bit
rates and resolutions, we
had to ourselves, in our
machine, encode at all those
different target bit rates.
And now we can just encode at
the highest bit rate that we
want users to be able to see.
We send that to YouTube, and
then YouTube actually takes
care of the transcoding
for lower bit rates.
So now you don't need a machine
that's as powerful as
what you needed previously.
JEREMY WALKER: Yes.
So basically, we built it from
the bottom up with our new
infrastructure.
So that's why we definitely
wanted to make some
improvements, so that's why the
new version is a little
bit different than
the last version.
MARTIN BELLEAU: And then also,
something that's surprising
from our users' point of view
is the users that we're
seeing, there's so many
different cases.
At first, we thought this
would be used mostly by
broadcasters or people at least
fairly familiar with
broadcasting.
But we're seeing education
conferences.
A whole bunch of people.
IKUYO YAMADA: Hospitals, or even
small community groups,
or corporates, they're wanting
to do a very high quality
video streaming, but yet they
don't really have an in-depth
broadcasting background.
So a very simple software like
this helps them to do that.
JEREMY WALKER: So you, actually,
with this new
version, you have some clients
using this now successfully
out in the field?
IKUYO YAMADA: Right.
We have a customer in Tokyo.
It's a broadcasting
company, Tokyo MX.
They're using Cambria Live to
stream all their music, and
also sports events, to their
YouTube Live Channel.
Here locally, we have Saber
Cats, which is an indoor
football team out of San Jose.
They use us to do all the
streaming of their games.
I recently did a project in
Seoul, worked with one of the
biggest broadcasters in Korea.
They did streaming of new music
live events, streaming
to their YouTube Live Channel.
So we do have quite a few
customer cases who are
already using it.
So it's a proven case that
it's working fine.
And they're very
happy with it.
And we're starting to see more
and more installation not only
in the US, but all
around the world.
So we're very excited and
happy about that.
JEREMY WALKER: I was going to
say, you're listing every
country, quite a
few countries.
That's really good to hear.
I guess, is there anything you'd
like to see added or
you're looking forward
to integrating with?
MARTIN BELLEAU: Well, something
that we want to do
more of is those Android apps,
like you were showing before.
There's a whole bunch of
different cases where that
could be useful since we need to
build our application to be
generic and used
by many people.
So in a bunch of instances,
we'd be better off with a
specific app.
So if you have a lot of sources
and you need switch
with them, then you'd want to
have small thumbnails on the
Android app so you can
switch easily.
In other cases, if you think
about education, you would
have a professor in front
of the class.
And using an app, you can change
from your PowerPoint
presentation or the DVI from
your laptop to the camera
itself that shows
the classroom.
So that's something
that we want to
pursue in the near future.
And yeah, we're looking forward
to whatever APIs you
guys come up with, and
we'll check them out.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah.
We'll definitely be
talking more.
Well, let's see if we had any
questions for you guys.
There was a question.
So we usually have general
questions.
There wasn't any specific
to Capella.
There was a question around
private videos.
And just for the people out
there, you can upload a
private video and only
you can see it.
And you can add a
couple users.
We do have a limit, but you can
add a couple users so only
they can see it.
And of course, you can't
download unless you uploaded
it, and you own the content.
And then the last question
is always on our side.
Is YouTube developer
relations hiring?
And yes, we are.
Definitely go check out the
developers.google.com/hiring
and have a look there to see if
any positions interest you,
because we're definitely
looking for people.
Well, thanks again, not only for
coming today, but also for
participating in Google I/O
at the YouTube Sandbox.
It was a really neat event, and
we were really happy to
have you guys.
And we look forward to
everything we can do now in
the future with the Live
Streaming API.
IKUYO YAMADA: Thanks for
having us today.
It was great to see you
and to be here.
MARTIN BELLEAU: Thanks.
IKUYO YAMADA: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]